everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm we are in round 4 of the
match of the century the 1972 World
Chess Championship between Bobby Fischer
and buddy Spassky game number 1 went to
Spassky Bobby Fischer not too happy
about how things went down went ahead
and forfeited game number 2 eventually
did come back to play game 3-1 that
winnette with the black pieces so he is
here in game number 4 with the white
pieces looking to even things up at two
games apiece so we're going to get into
it Bobby Fischer starts out with pawn to
e4 pawn c5 the Sicilian defense Knight
f3 pawn d6 pawn d4 pretty common
Sicilian defense opening moves from both
sides Knight to f6 Knight c3 Knight here
to c6 things change a little bit a Bobby
Fischer has lots of options as far as
how he wants to continue and he plays at
Bishop to c4 now at the time this kind
of thought to be called the the Suzan
attack now it's more commonly referred
to as the Bobby Fischer attack this is
what he played against the Sicilian
defense he really liked to bring his
Bishop here to c4 potentially bringing
his pawn to a3 kind of a safe little
outlet for his Bishop to come back here
on a2 really like to just control this
long light square diagonal almost kind
of keep it as a secret weapon sometimes
his opponents would even forget that it
was down here kind of controlling this
long diagonal but he just loved it bring
his Bishop here to c4 very very powerful
square most times your opponent's going
to be playing this pawn to e6 just to
fourth that attack a little bit just
kind of build up their pawn structure
that is what Spassky does pawn to e6 and
then Bishop back here to b3 now Bobby
because you're going to play pawn to f4
very aggressive way to attack this
eventually push up with pawn to f5
trying to break up the center control
but decides to go for a little bit safer
path and plays Bishop to b3 first now
Bishop to e7 getting grants castle on
the Kings side
Bishop e3 castle on the King side Kass
on the Kings side for Bobby Fischer and
then pawn to a6 just blocking off some
of these critical squares here b5 with
the knight coming here to b5 the knight
here to b5 just a nice safe defense
usually seen in the Sicilian defense
sometimes a little bit sooner
but in this variation as well just a
nice little solid defense black snap
pushing up too much material past the
six rank right here kind of just waiting
to see what Bobby Fischer does Bobby
Fischer decides to go for the more
aggressive route that pawn here to f4
this kind of tells but he's basket
exactly what he needs to do so decides
to start out with a knight taking on d4
so exchanging some of those nights off
the board Bishop takes back on d4 pawn
down here to b5 opening up the door for
his LightSquared Bishop you get involved
decided to go and play pawn day three
getting ready if he needs to to bring
his bishop back here 282 if it does ever
get into any problems a bishop here to
b7 just attacking the center the board
has both his bishop here on b7 and his
knights here on f6 of both attacking
this efore square and the sort of the
board now Bobby Fischer has just one
piece right here is knight on c3
defending this square so decides to go
and play Queen to d3 centralizing that
completing his development and also
adding a defender on this efore square
now but these basket asides to play
pretty interesting move right now and
it's pawn to a5 now what kind of happens
here is this knight on c3 it's attacking
this pawn on b5 and I really would like
to just take this right away go up in
material yeah that makes a lot of sense
but this Knights also tied to this efore
square and it doesn't want to move and
lose the center control because the
Queen can't recapture here so it decides
to first play pawn to e5 which is
exactly how it needs to after pawn to e5
pawn takes the pawn recaptures the
Knights forced to move the Knights also
although attacking the pawn here at E 5
it is being defended by this Bishop here
on d4 now the knight can take Lee come
up here on b5 and Bobby Fischer is up in
material but these baski plays Knight to
c5 and this is kind of where Bobby
Fischer makes a mistake in the game he
has a really really strong advantage
right now he has a pawn up and material
he's controlling the stern of the board
yes his opponent does have a very
powerful Bishop right here on b7
controlling these light diagonals but
his dark
a bishop isn't doing too much at all
which is really what he wants it's
keeping his opponent somewhat at bay
doesn't have many central pawns right
now this pawn on e6 isn't doing too much
does want to be able to make sure you
can get his rooks involved into the game
but all in all Bobby Fischer has a
strong game right now this Knights
attacking both the bishop and the Queen
this Bishop hasn't really done too much
although Bobby Fischer really likes his
likes for a bishop sometimes he can
overvalue it a little bit too much
because it's not doing much of anything
especially with this pawn here on e6
with the F pawn already gone it's not
going to be forcing this pawn to move so
there's less value in this LightSquared
Bishop Bobby Fischer probably should
have done is play the Queen to e3 I'll
kind of go through what he should have
done and then show you actually what he
did do so Queen to e3 his opponent
decided to take the bishop on b3 that's
fine he could just retake with his bit
as Queen here if the pawn kind of pushes
down a little bit
Queen to d3 and we kind of look at and
say things are still pretty good this
knight on b5 is fine it can come here to
d6 if it wants to later on Bishop can
always come it's controlling the center
of the board also blocking the Queen
familiar doing too much can always start
to push with the pawns here get his
rooks and bottom to the game this is
going to be very very good but he's fast
guy on the other side he can't really do
too much he can't get his queen involved
into the game it's kind of blocked off
by this Bishop parent e7 this Bishop on
b7 is nice but it can't do too much by
itself now if we come back on board and
say what did Bobby Fischer play he
actually took with his Bishop here on c5
the problem is when you recapture here
with Bishop takes on c5 all of a sudden
buddy Spassky has a very very strong
attack it's going to be very difficult
for either these bishops to be forced
off and they're both controlling this
King side of the board and that opens up
the door for this Queen to easily get
involved start attacking the King side
from Bobby Fischer so although Bobby
Fischer is up in material he all of a
sudden is under attack he right now is
in check he needs to move his king and
then I was in queen to g5 and he's under
fire queen el down here to G 2 is going
to be checkmate so we have to stop that
Queen down here e 2
over to d8 starting to put pressure on
this open D file our rook t1 after the
capture the rooks going to capture don't
want to come down here and capture with
your queen that is going to be checkmate
here on g2 Bobby Fischer's has to be
aware of so many things going on because
there's checkmate around the corner
wherever he's kind of going here and
then pawn to h5 so buddy Spassky looks
at and says okay I've got a strong
attack here I've got all my bishops kind
of aimed over to the Kings side this
knight on b5 is pointless now it can
maybe start to get involved into this
urn the board maybe block off a little
bit of the attacks the bishop here and
b3 is not doing anything it's going to
take a few moves just to get involved
into the game so let's go ahead and
start attacking on the Kings side see if
we can start to open up some of these
attacking lines and find it a strong
attack against Bobby fish right now but
these vas key has the lead it's all just
a matter of turning that into a victory
Bobby Fischer replies Knight to d6 does
have kind of this outpost here although
it's not the best outpost in the game
but this is attacking the bishop here
and b7 I'm going to be pretty easy just
kick back here on a8 c4 starting to try
to get involved into the game but it has
a few more moves for it can do anything
beneficial at all for Bobby Fischer pawn
to h4 pawn h3 just stopping the attack a
little bit Bishop down here III this is
a really nice attack it limits a lot of
the squares that Bobby Fischer can move
to in control this square here on e5 is
no longer being defended by the Queen
here on e2 so the Queen comes up here to
g4 says hey if you're going to take my
pawn on e5 I'm going to go ahead and
take your material back here so that's
exactly what we see Queen takes here on
e5 Queen takes here at age four and then
pawn to g5 also would have been pretty
interesting just play Bishop back here
to g5 attacking the Queen I think I
prefer this a little bit more but all in
all g5 is not too bad at all now Queen
to g4 Bishop back here c5 nights to b5
that's nice she's not doing anything too
productive a King here to g7 just bring
into the center a little bit more a
knight to d4 trying to find a little bit
better move rook over here to h8 Knight
to f3 Bishop takes here after the
Queen's
then we see the bishop here to d6 I
think it would have been much better
much stronger if the rook comes down
here to h4 attacking this Bishop you see
if we see the bishop moved down here to
f1 then all of a sudden Queen takes on
b2 and all of a sudden Billie's Spassky
is has a really good game here I can
start to gobble up material over here
this just seems really really strong if
instead no Bishop here to e2 then all of
a sudden rook to f4 starting to put more
pressure queen d3 queen takes on b2 all
of these seem really really good decides
to go and play Bishop back here to d6
now Queen here to c3 protecting the
square here on b2 which is very very
valuable for Bobby Fischer Bobby Fischer
realizes that he is no longer the
aggressor he's kind of trying to hold on
for a draw right here after the Queen
takes the pawn recaptures and then
Bishop here to e5 attacking this pawn
here on c3 a rook up here to d7 and then
King to f6 and this is important because
you may say okay well the bishop moved
here to e spy to attack this but if you
see Bishop take here then all of a
sudden Bishop taking on e6 and the pawn
can't take this all of a sudden this has
a very strong attack for Bobby Fischer
not where but if Spassky wants to be so
instead we see King to f6 on now King to
g1 both sides since the Queen's are off
the board I want to start getting their
Kings involved into the game now Bobby
Fischer he's up in material but at the
same time he does have double pawns here
it's gonna be very difficult for him to
hold on to both of these pawns and keep
that advantage but a Spassky on the
other side is a fine position but he's
kind of lost a lot of his initiative
that he had he had a better position he
could start to go up in material he had
a more active Queen involved he decided
to go and give up that Queen not sure if
he was intimidated by Bobby Fischer or
what but I do think he played a little
bit sub-optimally at the end of this
game so Bishop takes on c3 as we talked
about getting that material back Bishop
here to e2 Bishop e5 centralizing both
sides getting their kings involved
down here attacking the c2 pawn this
Bishop here attacking the f7 pawn with
the rook as well decides to go ahead and
the thin that the rook here on c7 is
being protected by the bishop on e5 so
after the exchange this is all fine and
well pawn to a4 King up here east 7 both
sides just don't really have a way to
win this game they're equal in material
they both have a bishop at the end of
the game so unless one side makes a
mistake it's just going to be difficult
to do too much we see King here to d3
Bishop e5 c4 King d6 both sides
centralizing but the Jews can't make any
headway
after c5 check both sides decide to go
ahead and tie so at the end of this
buddy Spassky after a game 4 still has
the advantage slightly we have a win win
and then a loss and then a draw from but
he's asking Bobby Fischer on the other
hand down a half a point going into game
5 where he will have the black pieces so
all in all really fantastic game I was
really impressed by buddy Spassky I
thought he was after he had just lost to
Bobby Fischer when Bobby Fischer had the
black pieces I really expect him to come
into game forward and just get destroyed
playing the black pieces but he came out
had a really really nice variation in
the Sicilian defense had the advantage I
think let it slip away at the end but
kind of proved to himself that he could
kind of get back in this even though he
had the lead with as far as games 1
almost think that he needed this as a
confidence boost boost Bobby fish on the
other hand still kind of thinks he's the
best but right now he has a lot of work
to do but there's many many more games
ahead of him so hopefully you guys are
enjoying the coverage I'll be doing game
5 shortly but thanks for watching I'll
see you guys in the next video